willkommen zu einer neuen folge von
thilo christ ist mir eine große freude
heute herrn professor volk ag hat von
der humboldt universität berlin
interviewern zu können und einen ganz
prominenten philosophen so niemand
geringerem als friedrich nietzsche hätte
hat worin würden sie sagen besteht
friedrich nietzsches philosophisches
relevanz und vielleicht noch aktualität
mit blick auf die heutige zeit
er resultiert von anfang an als zunächst
einmal als psychologe gegen die
philosophie und erst wenn diese nun
ausgesetzten widerspruch gegen die
philosophie zu einem klassiker der
philosophie geworden und das ist
wirklich eine einzigartige leistung es
gibt viele vorbilder in der europäischen
politik er hat sich auch an antiken
denkern orientiert aber geht mit einem
solchen furor gegen die gegenwart für
sowie an dass dies allein schon
lesenswert ist und uns sehr viel
aufschluss gibt über ganz bestimmte
verengen die disziplinierende studenten
auch in der philosophie des 19
jahrhunderts und ich halte ihn dafür
unentbehrlich als den mitlaufenden
widerspruch den wir brauchen
welches werk nietzsches würden sie
anfängern in vielen zu ersten kür in
welchen werken sind gesanges nietzsches
eigentliches anliegen am meisten
enthalten
ich stelle fest dass begann von der
disposition der junge leute oder auch
der älteren leute abhängen es sind viele
da wie durch den besonderen
mythologischen charakter von also sprach
verhandlungsraum sehr angetan sind sich
gar nicht davon abschrecken lassen ich
habe damit nicht angefangen und habe
mich auch sehr spät mit diesem buch
angefreundet das sage ich jetzt nicht
aus kritik einem buch sondern weil das
eben doch auch eine geschmacksfrage
essen auch diese reaktionen selbst
sollte man schon achten und es ist ein
fulminanter einstieg durch die geburt
der tragödie
aus dem geiste musik von 820 ein
unerhörtes hoch weil es eben in seiner
verteidigung der musik und der tragödie
und der scharfen kritik an
so hat es einen völlig neuen ton in die
philosophie des 19 jahrhunderts
überhaupt man kann sagen seit sokrates
einen völlig neuen ton bringt uns
zugleich aber nach einer abrechnung die
beispiellos ist
so kommt es im abschnitt 15 als den
eigentlichen retter der philosophie
bezeichnet weil so hat es die kultur der
menschen vor dem selbstmord gerettet hat
also da sieht man in diesem buch schon
die starke gewichtung die extremen
gegenden in denen er urteilt und das in
jeder hinsicht interessante und das
bleibt auch in den anderen werken so ich
könnte sehr empfehlen die zweite
unzeitgemäße betrachtungen über den wert
und den schaden berichtete die
geschichte für das leben hat eine damals
unter den bedingungen des historismus
dazu halsbrecherische these an dem wert
der geschichte zu zweifeln
er tut es aber eben auch hier mit der
erwartung dass man den raum frei bekommt
im eigenen leben selbst
und so könnte ich jetzt sogar vor
einigen großen am tourismus bücher
sprechen
sie haben etwas ganz eigenwilligen
eigenständiges bis hin zum letzten
abgeschlossenen buch über exe homo das
ist wirklich ein provokativer titel wäre
ein mensch wir wissen aus der geschichte
wer das sozusagen mit einer geradezu
göttlichen bedeutung im hinblick auf den
gekreuzigten gesagt hat sie scheut sich
nicht die aufzunehmen für sich und man
soll eben sehen dass er ein
klassischer mensch ein exemplarischer
denker ist und das ist interessant dass
von den europäischen denker der jüngeren
zeit keine so starke wirkung außerhalb
europas insbesondere in südamerika und
vor allen dingen in japan und china hat
und dann können wir sehen dass er in der
lage ist grenzen zu überschreiten und
eben menschen direkt anzusprechen
eine allerletzte frage wohin würden sie
liegt es konstruktives potential
entdecken viele lesen diese haltlosen
moral zertrümmerer als bloßen
relativierten sehen die bei nietzsche
ansatzpunkte für etwas konstruktives das
war meine überlegung auch zum begriff
des reifens auf der tagung die sie
veranstaltet haben uns werden sie
eingeladen haben
es ist natürlich zunächst einmal in
starkem maße destruktiv weil er eben die
geist konfektion die vor ihm vertreten
worden bin
für dual esstisch oder aber rein
metaphysische das muss man dann
natürlich auch erst einmal klären ich
bin nicht der ansicht dass die cce in
seiner auseinandersetzung mit seinen
vordenkern immer recht hat aber es ist
dann doch deutlich dass er in seiner
abgrenzung von dem was sie auf keinen
fall weiterführen will
neue einsichten hat und die nicht nur
mit blick auf kunst und kultur sondern
eben auch mit blick auf das was man ihm
gar nicht zutraut nämlich eine theorie
des bewusstseins und hier enthält sein
denken geradezu sensationell
moderne sind wem er das boot muss sein
nicht als etwas deutet das im kopf
hinter unserer stirn ist sondern er
verwendet dafür in ausdruck man höre und
staune verbindungsnetz und ist auch auf
der höhe einer beschreibungen wir auch
heute verwenden wenn wir vom world wide
web ja und damit haben wir einen guten
bezug zu unserer themen sendung fiel
okas die ja auch im internet
ausgestrahlt wird er gehabt vielen dank
für das interview und vielleicht ergibt
nicht demnächst mal die möglichkeit
wieder für ein gespräch danke für ihr
interesse erkennen